hey what's up i'm karen fian and i'm
here to answer the internet
[Music]
okay are there sacred days when you
refuse to masturbate
no
i love this so let's say like it was
like your friend's funeral
right is there a bathroom
like just what about in the morning and
like you're waking up and you're like
god
that's a long day ahead of us you
probably partied a little bit yeah
sounds like a perfect time to masturbate
and i feel bad
i'm like i showed up to my uncle's wake
in a crop top so
i was like ready what about uh 9 11 did
you mess with 9 11
you know i did not but i did have sex
so yeah i just moved here
like that night right it was like the
app was the morning and so
i was in college i was a freshman my
whole like class went back home
like they went back home to move home
with their parents and my mom called me
before it even hit like my grandmother
had come to her in a dream like
my i'm like a witch but no i just got
hammered all day i met these guys who
lived in astoria i had no idea where a
story was i thought it was so glamorous
a story a story oh wow great and um yeah
i had sex with this guy named pat
uh who had back knees
[Laughter]
oh my god would you put your kid in a
gorilla pit for 50 grand
um i'm barren so my kid in a gorilla
for how long is that a guess was that
witchcraft
i have three good eggs left um i don't
know
50 grand how long does he have to be in
there can i train him
can we lube him up
i'm saying if you put a slippery kid in
a gorilla pit he's going to have a
better shot
i'm kidding him in a [ __ ] bowl of
jelly
and we're good like listen kyle maybe if
you weren't such an annoying little [ __ ]
mom would it put you in the gorilla bit
if you had to watch one category of porn
for the rest of your life what would it
be
hot girl gangbang
answer yeah at least hmm girl i hang out
with you think so
it's mostly girls i hang out i feel like
the traditional girl answer would just
be like being born
i hate lesbian porn exactly
i'm into like really taboo stuff that's
not good like dr porn
like where the girls too young i just
don't edit this um
they're gonna come for me i love a hymen
check
[Laughter]
you know like a gang bang hyman check
that's like
that's okay they'll have like no like
they'll have the doctor calm like the
doctor
and he like checks her hymen and like
shows make sure she still has a hymen
and then the guy
that she's dating gets to break her
hymen while his best friend walks watch
it
watches
but that's when you'll start getting the
messages on the internet i don't think i
will
i like an actual video of a teenagers
[Laughter]
would you rather give up porn or sex for
one year
sex because i can still come if i watch
porn
it's something to do yeah yeah i mean
the frequency too you know
would you rather have your internet
history made public
or a sex tape that goes viral um
what i wouldn't mind having a sex tape
go viral at all
you would make it you would go you would
go hollywood if you had a psychiatrist
i mean i would write it there would be a
beginning middle and end there'd be
heartbreak there'd be laughter there'd
be
tears to be a real medical doctor
yeah i feel like that would be good for
business yeah i wouldn't mind that at
all
yeah of course every time i have sex i'm
like where
is the camera what are we doing here my
boyfriend's like pulling these shades
down i'm like leave them
up
what would you be afraid about with your
internet history going my internet
history is just gonna yeah
it's it's the word teen has just been
written too many times
oh my god
[Laughter]
sports and really everything in the
world right now are different
everything's a little off but lebat blue
light is doing everything they can
to make sure there's a degree of
normalcy in your life even without fans
in the crowd or without new shows on tv
they're doing what they can to help you
hashtag gear up tonight's featured
question from
the bat blue light you could gear up
with a million dollars or
push a button that gives you a 50 50
shot at 100 million
which you've taken 100 million okay this
sounds good
two buttons you can only press one a
instantly get a million dollars
b have a 50 50 chance you get 100
million
dollars i'm taking the mill i'm not that
risky
100 million like a million like you
still gotta work
no but i'm gonna flip that million you
don't even know i'm gonna get
by doing what i don't know we'll jazzle
my vagina with like millions of [ __ ]
diamonds that would be smart i would
take
every single dollar yeah invested in my
[ __ ] i'd be like this is a literal
million dollars
literally
only million but you can have only
million dollar clientele
it would be the ultimate million dollar
listing or you could advertise it as a
million dollar garage it could be a
parking spot
you pay you pay
[Laughter]
would you rather be a pig sorry would
you rather be
no whitney way thor um would you rather
be a pig
and be able to orgasm for 30 minutes or
be a lion and be able to have sex
60 times a day yeah i'd rather have sex
60 times a day
[Laughter]
30 minutes it's too long i feel like i i
like i sometimes bail on my own orgasms
after like four minutes i'm like get me
out of here we're getting in trouble
do you everything yeah i don't know like
before like it's a four minute orgasm
yeah sometimes
that's that's on its way to 30 minutes
it's a long [ __ ] time four minutes
i'm
saying with our ropes and glory we still
like that there's just something about
i've never seen a girl i've never made a
girl come for more than 10 seconds
but like one of the slow nba counts one
hardcore mississippi so four minutes
you've been coming for four minutes
yeah for the four minutes oh this is
with my vibration
this is what i'm watching like old man
young girl um
santa ten times um when you're drunk is
it better to get laid
or have the ideal drunk meal um i'm
obviously uh don't eat um
[Music]
eating for fat people so obviously have
sex
i don't even drink anymore but if you
answered eat a meal i've been [ __ ]
hfolio oh eat it
i'm hungry i've been here for 45 minutes
you guys don't even have some
cutery i love him
would you [ __ ] kelly ripa no bony [ __ ]
um
no would you [ __ ] kelly ripa if it had
to be a threesome with regents
regis would be the selling point for me
i don't [ __ ] want
bony ass i take bar classes
you are a bar if you were reading
the story of your life and you got to
the present day
so it'd only be 21 years long would you
keep reading knowing you can't change
anything you read it's just a that's a
very wordy way to say like do you want
to know that
yeah it is [ __ ] harry potter [ __ ]
wrote
the world this the future would you like
to see into
what was right no
no like do i want to know the future no
i want to make it
[Laughter]
i don't know i do know the future who is
the work
who is the one person in the world you
at least want to bang
who you at least would you want to bang
your significant other like
like what chick would i not want to bang
my current boyfriend
[ __ ] oh my god cause this would you
rather like
your boyfriend cheat on you with an ugly
chick or a hot chick um
that's a great question because if a guy
cheats on you with like a six that's a
dis
like that's me that's an insult to me
and what i look like if he cheats on you
with a chick who's hotter than him
or me he's probably not gonna get her
you know so that's
fine yes she was like oh i like batting
below so no
the thing is my boyfriend's a personal
trainer so if he
all of a sudden like most of the chicks
are like you know big they need help
right
but here's the scary thing about that if
he falls in love with their personality
and then they transform
right because i'm a [ __ ]
nothing redeeming as far as
personalities
what you see is
[ __ ] high-waisted pants all day
would you rather your boyfriend be able
to read your thoughts during sex
or all the time except during sex oh you
could definitely read them during sex
go for it because i love [ __ ] my
boyfriend my boyfriend's so hot
nobody find him would you rather a
throw up anytime yep no
would you rather sorry throw up anytime
someone says mcdonald's
or b wear a fedora for the rest of your
life and if anybody asks you about it
you have to say i like the way it looks
this is just rich boss's life this is
just
what he has to do um yeah i guess i'd
wear the fedora though
i like the way it looks would you rather
a
[ __ ] in the same position for the rest
of your life or be
only be able to jerk off to one porn
video i'd have to pick a because i
can't even watch the same video twice
and come to it i know really
yeah i mean there's a couple that i can
go back to and be like this will work
again but even then sometimes it doesn't
i need new [ __ ] every time
would you rather be the best looking
girl in the world or be able to read
minds best looking girl cause i need
all the money read minds what
i mean if you're the best looking girl
you can just assume everybody's saying
that girl's hot so it's kind of like
reading minds anyway
they're not thinking i bet she's smart
would you rather a be permanently hung
over or b
never be able to drink again well i
haven't had a drink in two and a half
years
thank you i'm a hero um so i
yeah that's fine this isn't i don't ever
want to drink again
hangovers suck they're brutal so you
don't miss it no
uh no and my hangovers were brew i would
just start drinking again
like when people say i have a hangover i
would be like why why don't you just
drink yourself into the hospital
bye spice nice
rock star of all rock stars being like
you just drink they both said at the
same time
yeah oh my god drinks that's what it is
let's do heroin yeah a little bit of
cocaine a couple of drinks
right you're just leveling out now we're
good
absolutely